there's been an awful lot going on but
most of it very disorganized and
individuals groups of the local
residents all organizing themselves
there's very little in the way of big
Mass organized help which is exactly
what they need here we've encountered
quite a lot of anger with them feeling
like they've been left to their own
devices we've seen people using pickaxes
hammers their bare hands to try and dig
beneath the rubble many relatives
talking about how they can hear their
relatives buried belief we've had
moments of real joy and hope as a very
small baby was taken out she came out
behind her she looks like she was in a
less well State she had a neck brace on
she was moaning quietly but she was
alive unfortunately those cases are very
few and far between here in antakia with
many corpses being found or more often
sheer frustration from the relatives who
can't get to their buried loved ones
beneath the rubble there are this is one
of the main streets into the entrance of
antakia and virtually every building has
been affected we've seen one of the
private hospitals which has just
collapsed with the top floors just
sitting on the pancake of all the bottom
floors
are now just flat on the ground and
underneath them there are relatives who
are saying that they can still hear
voices we've seen children being brought
out
unfortunately we haven't survived and
it's a pretty desperate terrible scene
here a lot of people very frustrated
shouting at us venting their anger about
why why isn't there anyone here helping
we've seen just one Digger which was
trying to clear clear the road clear a
path and trying to and he was beset upon
by
um a lot of the the locals who were
trying to plead with him to come and
look look up the rubble around
here on their own and the local police
said they'd commanded their sticker a
lot of them complaining about how they
feel the government is ignoring part of
Turkey